wie jeden tag mit den passenden deckel
wie meinst du das
musste die abschminken er ist nicht der
richtige für dich ich war total verliebt
hieß fahrt und beim richtiger traumteam
er war in zusammenziehen und heiraten
aber mein vater war dagegen
er meinte ich sehr jung war das richtige
für mich
das hat mir gefallen lassen die hat es
ja nicht böse gemeint hat sich einfach
nur sorgen gemacht deswegen hast du
fahrrad verlassen
glücklicherweise hatte mein vater recht
hart und ich das könnte auf dauer nicht
funktioniert
da wie du siehst kann die große liebe
später auch noch kommen
wenn das projekt abgeschlossen ist dann
da muss ich erst mal eine kleine auszeit
nehmen irgendwohin fahren ganz weit weg
ich habe dein vater gebeten mich danach
freizustellen
ich bin nicht die richtige für dich
das weiß ich und du bist nicht der
richtige für mich
auf die freiheit
über eine kurze fahrt zum träumen
freunde ich muss euch etwas sagen
es mag heute nicht der richtige
zeitpunkt sein aber es ist eine
überraschung
jetzt macht es nicht so spannend
genau wie wendig jünger jetzt lasst das
mädchen nummer zu wort kommen
als aller erstes möchte ich euch danken
ich bin vor einigen jahr nach
deutschland gekommen weil die kunst
studieren
wir sind quasi ineinandergerast
hauptbahnhof und ich hab ich hab so
wahnsinnig viel gelernt seitdem unter
anderem das kenne ich habe von anfang an
gewusst dass du genau die richtige für
mein laden bist obwohl ich kölsch und
pils ständig verwechselt habe jetzt
arbeitest du hier
ich kann nur sagen js jährlinge manager
beauty ringe
beruflich habe ich mich starren nämlich
nicht persönlich vincent steigern dürfen
in der anfangszeit ja eher weniger aber
auch damals was ziemlich erfreulicher
weise eines besseren belehrt bei mir war
so ich hab dich letztendlich überzeugt
die auswahl unserer mitbewohner war
teilweise sehr unglücklich ja meine
beste freundin und mein bester freund
sind ein paar eine doofe konstellation
sage ich euch ja ja du hast mir ja auch
mein freund ausgespannt
sag mal und die schlagfertigkeit hat sie
von ihnen verloren
ich habe dich so kennen und lieben
gelernt
und dich damit am meisten verletzt
es waren turbulente zeiten für mich und
ich merke jetzt einfach dass ich zeit
brauche um mich und mein leben wieder in
ordnung zu bringen
und deswegen
habe ich entschieden
ich gehe zurück nach brasilien